The Daily Beast has just a blockbuster
article out which if it's accurate
confirms what would be really the first
publicly known connection between Trump
staffers and associates and not just
Russians but Russian intelligence
operatives known colloquially sometimes
as Russian spies and we're talking here
about Rick gates Rick Gates is the
business partner a former Trump campaign
chairman Paul Manafort both of whom have
been indicted by special prosecutor
Robert Muller and what The Daily Beast
has learned and is reporting is that the
prosecutors working for Robert Muller
have now been able to directly link
gates to a person tied to Russian
intelligence obvious question we should
all have when The Daily Beast reports
this how do we learn how did they learn
this and the way that they learned this
is because of court filings that were
released a couple of days ago which say
that Gates and an unnamed person who
worked for one of Paul mana forts
companies were in touch in the months
leading up to the November of 2016
election I think they specifically know
even September and October August
September October somewhere in that
range and they've described the
connections between gates and this
individual linked to Russian
intelligence as quote pertinent to the
investigation meaning Robert molars
investigation into Trump Russia
coordination collusion and possible
criminality the court filing the same
court filing that's the basis of this
daily beast report also says and this is
the key part right that gates knew that
this individual was connected to Russian
intelligence and if true absolutely huge
absolutely huge because this is crossing
the line into knowing and deliberate
contact specifically for the purposes of
the Donald Trump campaign with
individuals in the Russian government in
this case it's even more specific
specific in the sense that it's Russian
intelligence operatives now there are
people who will hear me say this and
I'll get call the calls from them emails
live calls who knows maybe tomorrow
we'll hear from some of them who will
say David there is
simply no evidence that a crime took
place no matter what coordination there
was no matter what quote collusion there
was but that now is also a narrative
that we have to refute because the list
of possible crimes here continues to get
longer and longer the more we learn
about what took place so accepting
assistance and things of value be they
money or information as we've talked
about from foreign entities for a
federal election in the United States is
a crime right that's one possible crime
that is on the list here covering up
those incidents of receiving things of
value also a crime obstructing
investigations into those incidents
regarding the receipt of things of value
from foreign entities for elections is
also a crime lying to investigators
about those incidents is a crime and
when multiple people work together to
either cover up or obstruct or mislead
that can also be the crime of conspiracy
and the talking point from the Russia
denialists and there's some on the right
and there's some on the left as you
probably well know at this point is
David collusions not a crime
collusion simply is not something that
is a crime in the criminal code that's
sort of like saying killing people with
guns isn't a crime I can find no crime
called or described as killing people
with guns well just because it's not in
the Criminal Code that way doesn't mean
it isn't this thing called murder right
and that starts to become really a
semantic disagreement colluding where
the foreign entity provides things of
material value is a crime it wouldn't be
called the collusion but we're speaking
colloquially here about the various
crimes that might be included under that
umbrella
now also stunning is that this story
barely registered yesterday in the midst
of news about Trump bragging about
what's going on with North Korea stormy
Daniels Trump missing from the public
eye with absolutely nothing scheduled up
until today for long periods of time
Facebook story and he
if this story did get more coverage the
committed trumpets aren't going to care
right they'll talk about what what's
going on with Donald Trump and
unemployment or whatever the same
unemployment numbers that they didn't
believe under President Obama and in
fact I saw the other day on CNN the day
that CNN reared Anderson Cooper's 60
minutes interview with stormy Daniels
CNN sat down with a bunch of Trump
voting women I don't remember where it
was I think it was somewhere in the
south and it was just total cognitive
dissonance right some of them saying
this was a long time ago others saying
we simply don't believe it others saying
Trump's personal life all of a sudden
just isn't a concern for us because his
legislative positions are Christian and
close to God so if you're waiting around
as I know there are some people waiting
around they email me they say David as
soon as X happens then the trumpets will
fully abandon Trump no they won't the
trumpets are ideologically and fully
committed to Donald Trump and the extent
to which cognitive dissonance is going
to keep them there goes well beyond
another dozen accusers of sexual assault
against Donald Trump or even more
connections here with Russia so we've
got to just forget about them and we've
got to do whatever we can to make sure
that justice is carried out here because
they're not going to come over to the
side of logic and reason the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership